foreign
[Music]
The Flash has an impact on the next
Batman movie a Terminator star joins
stranger things season 5 and there are
First Impressions from the live action
series one piece and avatar The Last
Airbender Chris Hemsworth speaks about
lore5 and there is confirmation about
appearances of Woody and Buzz Lightyear
in Toy Story 5. welcome to keynotech
news
stranger things meets Terminator at
Netflix's to Doom event an exciting
addition to the cast of The Fifth and
final season was announced especially
fans of the old movies of The Terminator
franchise could be particularly excited
about this the announcement came from
Arnold Schwarzenegger who is Netflix's
Chief action officer during the annual
to Doom event Schwarzenegger revealed
that a long time Terminator co-star
Linda Hamilton will be part of the
upcoming final season of stranger things
in a video message she shared her
enthusiasm and anticipation for the new
role however the details about
Hamilton's character remain top secret
and have not been elaborated on filming
on the final season of stranger things
was originally scheduled to begin these
days but it has been delayed due to The
Sensational writer strike work on the
scripts for The Fifth Season began back
in August of last year and is believed
to be mostly complete it was by the way
decided by the showrunners and executive
producers Matt and Ross Duffer to
postpone the production instead of
shooting without the writers on the set
as a result of these delays the start of
filming and streaming of the final
episodes of stranger things remains
uncertain it is expected that the
kickoff of the final season will not
happen before 2024 but we will of course
keep all fans updated in the coming
months
so the flash does have an impact on the
DCU more specifically on the future of
Batman the boss's Peter Safran and James
Gunn were so impressed by the movie that
director Andy muschetti was directly
hired for the future Batman the Brave
and the bowl mushietti is no stranger to
Warner Brothers he previously directed
the two successful remakes of it now
that the flash has also been a success
he will be involved in the creation of
the new DCU Batman the Brave and the
Bold is expected to shed light on a
whole new side of Batman with the debut
of Damian Wayne Bruce Wayne's son goes
up against the villains of Gotham City
in this version as Robin the movie will
be based on the comic by Grant Morrison
in which Damian Wayne trained by
Rochelle ghoul takes on his well-known
role this creates some tension because
Damian Wayne is clearly tougher and more
uncompromising than his father the
script is still in the works but it is
already cleared that the movie will not
be related to Matt Reeves the Batman 2.
thus will not be set in the DC elsewhere
the choice of mushieri as the person in
charge of the movie is justified by
Peter saffron and James Gunn in this way
he is a Visionary director and a big DC
fan himself mushieri and his sister
Barbara who will also co-produce the
film with their company double dream are
an extraordinary team and moreover the
best partners for the new DC film so the
conditions are obviously very good for a
movie that should also be well received
by the fans an official release date for
Batman the Brave and the Bold is
currently unknown
Chris Hemsworth has a clear opinion
about Thor 5. the 39 year old was
interviewed by the trade magazine
Entertainment Weekly in which he made it
very clear that things could not go on
the same as before after the mixed
reviews for Thor 4 love and thunder the
future of the movie series remains
uncertain however Chris Hemsworth who
has played the Norse god of thunder in
nine movies has not fully concluded with
his role in addition to last week's
conversation with Entertainment Weekly
he already commented on a possible
comeback for Thor 5 last November on the
happy sad confused podcast Hemsworth
stressed that he has to be careful about
how he phrases his statements because he
doesn't have any precise information
about the next phase of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe officially he said he
knows absolutely nothing even though
there are always talks similar to his
role in extraction Hemsworth can
currently be seen in the Netflix
production extraction 2 where he
embodies the presumed dead mercenary for
the second time he did however set one
important condition for his return as
Thor he didn't want to play the role
until viewers were worn out as soon as
they saw him on the big screen moreover
Hemsworth emphasized that a return would
have to be accompanied by an important
change involving his character he said
that he doesn't know whether he will be
invited back at all but if so Thor would
need to be markedly different than in
the previous films after the last two
films directed and written by taika
waititi there were criticisms from
different quarters that the hero had
become too ridiculous and that the plot
could no longer be taken seriously thus
remains to be seen whether and in what
form we will see Chris Hemsworth as Thor
again in a possible fifth part we will
keep an eye on the statements of the
parties involved and let you know as
soon as something new comes up
the new live-action series avatar The
Last Airbender is rocking the boat
during the worldwide Fan event to Doom
in Sao Paulo Brazil the main characters
and a short teaser could be seen the
first shots of the Netflix version of
the extremely popular Nickelodeon series
were met with mixed feelings the first
attempt at a live action feature filmed
by M Night Shyamalan is still regarded
as a huge flop accordingly fans are
critical of the new effort to adapt the
cult series with real humans the new
images show Gordon Cormier as the main
character Aang Soka actor Ian ousley
kiawentio escatara and Dallas Liu as
Zuko the latter is the Crown Prince of
the Fire Nation and is expected to play
a significant role in the upcoming
series while the costumes and makeup of
the four main characters basically
reflect the designs of the Animated
Series many see it more as a failed
attempt at cosplay in spite of the
doubts others do praise the style and
are looking forward to the Netflix
adaptation all the more after seeing the
teased footage by the way one of the
central aspects of casting in production
according to those responsible is the
representation of diversity a subject
that showrunner Albert Kim already
addressed in an interview in August of
2021 fans of the original series will be
eagerly but skeptically waiting for more
information especially after the
creators of the original series Michael
Dante dimartino and Brian coneyetsko
left the project they felt that the
Netflix production was heading in the
wrong direction an official release date
for The Eight Episodes of the series is
currently unknown but it is anticipated
that avatar The Last Airbender will be
released during 2024.
well Toy Story 5 have to get by without
Woody or Buzz Lightyear this question
preoccupied many fans when the sequel to
Toy Story 4 was announced after all the
popular animated characters went their
separate ways in the end Pixar boss Pete
doctor now gave the answer in an
interview with variety the two will
definitely be returning in Toy Story 5.
although it is still not clear how
exactly both characters will be reunited
Buzz was last seen Solo in theaters but
there were rather mixed reactions to the
light year spin-off nevertheless the Toy
Story film series remains one of Pixar's
most successful franchises Toy Story 4
alone generated around 1.1 billion US
dollars at the box office in 2019. by
the way Toy Story 5 was already
announced back in February alongside
Frozen 3 and zootopia 2 though an exact
release date has yet to be confirmed
fans worldwide are eagerly awaiting
further details on how the story of
Woody and Buzz will continue as soon as
there is news we will let you know of
course
one piece becomes a live action series
and now the first trailer is here it was
presented at the Netflix event to doom
and shows important characters like
Luffy Zorro and Nami in action however
the reaction to the realization are very
mixed amongst fans on the internet the
series tells the story of Luffy the
rubber light captain of the straw hat
Pirates much like in the popular anime
series he sails across the ocean from
Island to island with a crew of Misfits
always in search of a mysterious
treasure called the one piece the
leading role is played by inyaki Godoy
in addition we see makenu asoro Emily
rudiznami Jacob Romero Gibson as Usopp
and Taz Skyler as Sanji while some are
completely thrilled by the trailer and
can hardly wait for the series to start
others are critical of the poor effects
and make their disproval of the
live-action version abundantly clear
tomorrow Studios which also produced the
live action version of Cowboy Bebop for
Netflix is in charge of the project we
will see how the new one piece series
performs in comparison and whether the
opinion of fans will change once again
upon release on August 31st 2023 on
Netflix
that concludes the news for this week
what do you think of the news and is
there any other relevant information
that you've heard of tell us about it in
the comments by the way DC fans among
you can stay right on our Channel as we
provide an interview of all upcoming DCU
movies in a recent original episode
please check it out we also have a brief
movie preview for alien Romulus on our
Channel if you're interested thanks for
watching and see you next week for more
kenocheck news
[Music]
thank you